tell me okay hi guys we're here with
Tyler Oakley
Oh he does some sound effects you will
be then mode so we shot a video over on
Tyler's channel where I got to live out
my dreams of being cindy-lou who and
Tyler I printed this so make sure you go
over on his channel and watch that
because we played the humming challenge
to figure out Christmas songs and they
thought staying in the festive spirit we
would play a little game of never have I
ever to find out who's been on the
naughty list this year and there it is I
was like where's the connection going to
connect she made it I tweeted out for
you guys to send us never have I ever
questions
Diane has collected them in this
beautiful hat I guess so we have a bunch
of questions that I haven't even seen in
here and we're gonna go back and forth
and play never have I ever
so do you hold up ten fingers or five
fingers what's the deal so yeah the
basics it was it's on channel we're
gonna play where you want five fingers
and basically the question it gets asked
and if you have done what the question
is asking you lose a finger because that
means you're naughty I recently was
grinding with the guy with only four
fingers and I found out while we were
holding hands and I was grinding with
them and I was like there's nothing
wrong with having nine fingers but I was
like am I really suck if there's no
subtle way to be like so anyway okay
let's begin we start with five and we
see who's gonna be the naughtiest first
did you check that secondly nails I'll
start off okay the first one I'm putting
down people don't you see that never
have I ever been the culprit for
someone's love life going down in flames
mmm meaning like I broke up with someone
and they look like you broke two people
apart I'm no homewrecker no I have you
ever like exposed somebody's boyfriend
to them and be like listen I need to
tell you the truth about your terrible
boyfriend or husband No thank God I have
I think I'm clear on this we sustained
we're nice we still have our fingers
never have ever been in a throuple a
three-person
and chip it's fun getting into throuple
that's like you that's not a threesome
no it's a relationship base three party
only Tiffany emotion yeah where you all
want to be there together no I can't do
no selfish never have I ever hooked up
with someone at a youtube related event
[Music]
oh there we go that's a hard one never
ever joined the mile-high club
I am define the mile-high club having
sex in a plane that you're a mile above
the ground at least you have sexual
relationship good sis Kilimanjaro what
does somebody know and I come and drive
but I don't think that counts Texan to
the mile-high club is in a plane which
seems so hard to do it never have I ever
accidentally like someone's really old
photos oh yeah big time I don't know
what the time frame is on when someone
gets alerted when you've liked their
photo they get it right away really have
known the G no I don't even mind I'll go
like two years deep in like four
pictures I want the message to get
across your deep-diving yes ma'am
never have ever blocked a toilet in
someone else's house and not told them
about it yeah in the house that we shot
Mikey show all the plumbing was bad the
12 got clawed a couple times during the
season and then the last time I got
clogged cuz they always just blame the
crew so last time it was me but I blame
the crew I am positive this has happened
so I'm just gonna finger dad I don't
have a specific answer right but lord
knows I've done it never have I ever
flirted to get something for free well
yeah meaning what would be flirting I'm
not good at
and to get something for free give me
your best shot I've got waka moly it can
be free I'm good no you and Naima are
the masters of this what's the best free
thing that you've gotten from flirting
I don't know specifics I'm sure like to
cut the line like the Apple store or
like to cut the line at Disneyland I
just don't like to wait for things yeah
she's a bossy impatient girl never have
ever accidentally sent an intimate
picture to the wrong person no no I
don't take you into my picture no me
either I'm too paranoid you really
simple no no especially because people
can look at your stuff on your computer
and your phone why do you think all your
ads are tailored exactly to what you're
looking at retweet okay never have I
ever been dating two people at the same
time I've had to have a serious
conversation with someone that thought
we were more serious when I met someone
else that I was more interested in I
don't think this is a fair question cuz
dating is like girl you're dabble in
that place going over here with somebody
like serious with two people that wants
anyhow to like figure it out because
otherwise my finger is going down are
you naughty yeah yeah we're all naughty
that's what this game is meant to prove
that everyone's not me no one's nice
that they're nice they're lying the
reward is that you guys get to go watch
the video that we made over on Tyler
they're so blessed you really are
because I have you noticed my video
could not look Tyler in the face at all
it was intimate
go watch Tyler's video the link will be
in the description box below and go
check Tyler out across all social media
platforms just at Tyler Oakley right
jobless and if you're one of my people
subscribe to Grace and like this video
and comment with something very sweet I
think something sweet would be nice
sure I was gonna say tell us
Nonnie you've done to make us feel like
yeah yeah sorry yeah wait okay just for
funsies I want to see maybe someones
birth never have I ever thought I saw a
ghost
I've thought I saw a ghost no ever never
I don't believe in that [ __ ] see if I
see something like wicked e wicked eat I
think it's a reflection from the back of
my glasses and I just let my brain think
that mine is always like oh there's the
devil lives in my house no never have I
ever wet the bed in my adult life no I
have work yeah okay never have ever
cheated on the test go hell yeah yeah
cheered I made I was always out here a
million little note simulator so my
graphing calculator was for only in the
slot that it shoved into I would just
peek around never have I ever lied to
another friend about where you are
because you are with someone they don't
like yeah yeah I've done that I was here
to protect my friends you're right I am
alright